On to the next question regarding the
social impact of fasting. Um there are
any specific areas that you can shed
light on for us today? As far as the
social impact is concerned in fasting,
the person realizes
about the other human beings who are
poor, who don't have food, who don't
have shelter and it makes us realize
that how does it feel when a person is
hungry. Many of us who are rich, who
have no problem of feeding food, when we
fast, we realize how does it feel when a
person is hungry. So our love and our
care for the poor people increases. And
furthermore, even we realize the
boundaries of Allah subhananaa tala. How
many times do we really thank Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala for the food he has
given us for the water. Imagine the air
that we get that we breathe. How many
times do we thank Allah for that? So the
food the water which Allah provides us.
The rich people hardly their mind goes
towards it. But while fasting they
realize that it helps them to care for
the poor people. It also helps them in
being generous with the other human
beings in sharing with other human
beings. It also helps in forgiving other
people's fault. So fasting helps to
society in various ways. And furthermore
our beloved prophet wasallam said it's
mentioned in Sai Aljame number one had
number 896. The beloved prophet said
that
if you have mercy on those on the earth
then those who are in the heaven they
will have mercy on you. That means if
you're merciful to the other human
beings Allah subhana wa ta'ala will have
mercy on you. So this fasting it helps
us in building the society better. It
helps us in being generous, helps us in
being loving, in caring with the other
human beings. And besides
not only in the poor people, it helps us
in being good with all the human beings.
It helps us in being good with the
family. Helps us in being good with
society. And many of times we don't
realize that we don't give enough time
to our family. Especially in the western
world, at least in fasting, you're with
your family twice. And people make it a
point that in fasting at least they
should do the sur with their family and
at least break the fast with the family.
So at least they are with the family
twice in the day. So the bonding in the
family increases the family get
together. The parents get more closer to
the children. Especially in the western
world where this neglected
as far as the society is concerned
it is very helpful in getting the
society together. We many a time go to
our neighbors during ifar we call our
friends call our neighbors and the
beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said it's mentioned in say
Muslim volume number three had number
5379 the prophet said whenever you
invited do not refuse so people invite
each other during during the month of
Ramadan so it helps in getting the human
beings closer to one another whether it
be the neighbors whether it be the
society at
And it's also a very good time for
self-improvement as well as doing Isla
and dawa. We meet people in the mosque.
Many people who don't go to the mosque
at the month of Ramadan they come to
mosque. We meet them. We can chat with
them. We go for tarawi. And this is the
time we can do islah. We're going to daw
with the non-Muslim. And as you rightly
said, Ramadan was the month the time we
change your heart. And Allah gave you
haya. This is very important. And that's
why the beloved prophet wasallam said
mentioned in suni had number 1924 that
Allah bestows his mercy on those
who themselves show mercy to others.
Again a prophet says and he continues in
this hadith that if you are merciful the
merciful will show mercy on you. And he
further says that if you show mercy to
those on earth, those in the heavens
will show mercy to you. So fasting helps
in building up the society and getting
people closer to one another.